hey josh where did you get that lollipop
oh hi martin the slipslap candy company
came by and asked for help
connecting their code to a google
spreadsheet i told them
we might have something for you sounds
great
stay tuned if you want to know more
[Music]
i met with max from slip slap candy
company he explained that many of their
internal systems need to know
what ingredients they have in their
warehouse it turns out
the warehouse staff already keeps track
of this in a google sheet
that's great news because it's easy to
read a google sheet from google cloud
platform
max didn't want to deal with server
setup and maintenance so we went
serverless and picked cloud run
and he has previous experience in
javascript so we decided to use node.js
together with the express web framework
cloud run
code executes as a default identity the
compute
default service account max opened the
warehouse spreadsheet
clicked the share button and gave that
account view access
to the spreadsheet then he enabled the
sheets api
in slipslap's gcp project max designed a
really simple rest api with only one end
point
if you hit slash ingredient id you will
get the warehouse details for that
ingredient the express library makes it
easy to pick up the ingredient id
and take action on it once max has the
ingredient id
he can call the get ingredient function
and return that ingredient to the caller
in json form the code for reading from
the google sheet
is in the get ingredient function it
creates an auth object with the
spreadsheet scope
it then reads columns a through e for
all rows that have
any data notice how there are no
passwords keys
or oauth secrets the account running
this code
already has read-only access to the
sheet once the sheets api returns the
rows from the sheet
max can loop over them find the
ingredient with the right id
and return that ingredients data to the
calling function
check the video description below for
the link to the full code example
this code reads all rows in the sheet
every time the rest api is called
that's okay for a small sheet like this
slipslap only has about a thousand
ingredients in their sheet
if you have a much larger data set you
should use a regular database like cloud
firestore or cloud sql
as the warehouse staff updates the
spreadsheet the rest api will always
return the latest data
max loves this as that means he doesn't
have to write a separate admin user
interface
that's less than 50 lines of code for a
simple read-only rest api
that's backed by a google sheet nice
well max gave me this u.s one dollar
bill
he wonders how much could slipslap use
this service for that dollar
let's say slipslap's internal systems
hit this service on average
once every 30 seconds 24 hours a day
seven days a week this would fit
comfortably within the free tier for
cloud run
and they wouldn't have to pay anything
but what if they've used up their fury
tier
running other cloud run services in that
case
it would cost slip slap a little under
one us dollar
to run this service for one month not
bad
i'm also sure max is happy he doesn't
have to manage any servers
yeah i think so uh josh uh max didn't
give you another one of those lollipops
by any chance
[Music]